mon premier sentiment c'est
effectivement un président qui au bout
de deux ans d'exercice du pouvoir
découvre la réalité sociale et la
fracture territoriale dans notre pays je
dirais il était temps mais pour autant
il vient pas d'inflexion au contraire un
entêtement dans la poursuite de réformes
qui s'avèrent des réformes parfois de
régression sociale
on nous annonce un progressisme contre
le nationalisme dans les élections
européennes et ce qu'on voit c'est
effectivement des propositions qui vont
dans la régression sociale
quand je pense notamment à la retraite
ou fait finalement d'allonger la durée
de cotisation c'est s'est allongée passé
c'est retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est donc en fait diminuer les
pensions pour les gens qui sont en
précarité ou pour les salariés qui se
sont vus abîmé dans leur santé par leur
travail
donc finalement c'est une paupérisation
à venir encore plus importante des
retraités
donc voila moi je vois des révélations
et le social vous attendiez une
inflexion vous attendiez à ce qu'il
change de cap
malheureusement je ne l'attendais pas
mais j'aurais j'aurais aimé être
surprise et ce que je vois c'est
effectivement un entêtement et puis le
fait de reposer toujours la réussite sur
non pas sur les protections qui sont
fondées sur la solidarité c'était ça
notre modèle social
mais sur les responsabilités
individuelles et encore une fois sur
l'assurance chômage
il renvoie aux responsabilités
individuelles des chômeurs comme quoi
c'est ça le levier pour lutter contre le
chômage c'est pas la création d'emplois
avec emmanuel macron c'est de
responsabiliser les chômeurs comme si
leur situation
elle était la conséquence de leur choix
eux ce qui est totalement faux
ils sont les victimes d'un système
économique qui qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas je dirais bénéfique à tous
et puis évidemment on attendait on nous
avait on nous avait annoncé une
inflexion en termes de prise de
conscience de l'urgence climatique et
écologique et on ne la voit pas on ne la
voit pas elle est absent de se dressent
encore une fois une défense écologistes
et de défense espère qu'on va je dirais
prendre le pouls des citoyens
éventuellement pour de nouvelles mesures
contraignantes serre que là on va on va
leur faire passer la pilule parce qu'ils
auront participé alors qu'on ne parle
pas des grandes entreprises qui polluent
qui actuellement menace notre santé part
par le fait d'utiliser des substances
chimiques de ne pas lutter contre la
pollution de l'air de pour les grandes
banques pour total de financer des
projets
dans les énergies fossiles enfin on
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux là